the most realistic thing we've ever seen
in they showcas the Xbox series oh my
God oh my God he's like yeah that fil
came out that's gameplay y'all just to
let you know this ain't this that's the
real game all right first second time we
see it troll on the beach is the biggest
Sprite I've ever seen she throwing on
the she got soldiers she got a whole
team of soldiers behind the throwing
Spears we like yeah this the game this
we like yo that look like a cinema no
that's the game that's the game that's
what they tell us no I understand okay
but that doesn't mean that doesn't exist
within a linear path is not talking
about you talk about that's what I mean
like that's what I mean by scope right I
I don't look at it like that I look at
it when I played hellblade one right